weil ist der zieleinlauf ist oder was
geht ab hier soll max und heute gibt es
eine runde bildete zusammen mit dem
lieben sturm waffel allerdings nicht
wundern wurde meine face com leider
nicht aufgenommen und ja das wollte ich
euch nur wissen lassen nicht dass hier
denkt machte es keine fenster mehr
das gab leider einfach nur probleme bei
dem aufnehmen naja viel spaß mit dem
video ich kann super bauern parcours
gerne das ist echt jump'n'run anders
überlegt auch so da ist ein parcours und
durchläuft oder einem parcours eine
parkuhr für die musik hierbei voll
stellen das ist finde ich weiß überhaupt
nicht was ich jetzt machen soll macht so
selbst ein parcours bitte ich meist
verschiedene ich sage ich will eine
entschuldigung mir leid du sollst mir
nicht helfen vielleicht will ich auch
gar nicht geholfen bekomme ich will ich
will ganz geholfen werden bekommt
heraufsetzen jump'n'run oder was man
dazu sagt
somit selber klarkommen bitte sagt sturm
bietet mit dieser akt sagt jetzt ich hab
voll ins training kann man jetzt die
frage kann ihn etwas verkackt ist
parkour ist aber auch echt ein blöder
begriff
richtig blöd ich baue jetzt ein richtig
cooler chur
nein das glaube ich nicht aber wie soll
ich denn jetzt so schnell ein paar
kurven er dass sein
der steht hier passt einfach besser so
das ist jetzt ja sehr schön
okay ich mache schon richtig cool super
parcours ich meine richtig kubatur drei
minuten a
und das ist aber voll alternativ und
zwei gott ich glaube die alle werden
mich besiegen sein
funktioniert das funktioniert
funktioniert ich habe den anspruch ein
parcours ist so gut wie es passiert ist
nicht mehr fallen keine geräte möglich
eines taxis phase
das ist verboten takeshi's castle es war
mal verboten eine ganze zeit lang wie in
europa kein scheiß nicht funktioniert
nicht was ich machen will
gegen ende richtig
hey wir seit wann springen die nicht
mehr diese blöcke ausleihen blog es geht
auch dieses line blogs oder wie heißen
die auf dem man springen kann und er
springt nicht bei mir
höher waren
das finde ich turm habe ich gesagt
glaubte besitzt ja und dann glaubt es
halt ich glaube das hat auch was mich
nicht her
das hält mich nicht dieser feder der
block b
das muss schon dafür machen
im spielmodus rush modus
ich werde modus genau wissen und mir
fällt nichts mehr ein was ich machen
kann cool es nicht mehr
nein nie takeshi's castle geguckt nein
warum
das sieht dann spektakulär aus mache
weil ich bei all dem ist so schöne
challenges checken
da muss man wirklich sein dass
challenges integriert ich wäre gespannt
auf die anderen auch so einen bretter
und den gemacht haben wie wir oder die
nicht so dumm sind wir alle ob es
funktioniert überhaupt und ich bin auch
richtig auf jeden fall was womöglich
nicht fertig wie macht man noch einmal
feuerwerk die feuerwehr hat man nicht im
inventar ich hab irgendwann irgendwas
habe ich jetzt gemacht bin mir nicht
sicher es ist alles nicht alles nicht so
richtig
ich bin gespannt was die anderen gemacht
haben sich sechs nämlich nicht ob wir
einfach so ein jump'n'run gemacht haben
oder er appelliert übertreibt man es
richtig gut
mach mal epic guter weg von mir erhalten
ok
spannend ist für mich ein ich kann also
ist okay okay das haben sie wohl einfach
darunter verstehen
also vielleicht einfach nur grünen block
genommen anstatt ins leben gewartet das
leid auch das ist nicht so dass wirst
okay okay würde ich sagen oder auch dazu
okay okay ist nichts besonderes
der untergrund arzt job gemacht okay da
bin ich der einzige der bis dato etwas
anderes gemacht hat er auch aber das
will ich auch gut weil man muss ja auch
andere sachen
theoretisch sind oder dass ich sie die
kletter war ja hauptsache hat er bei dir
funktioniert funktioniert doch klar es
wird hier war cool
beides probiert
bei einer schon jene gut ich habe gut
gegeben alter die machen alle bessere
sachen als ich ich bin echt mal gespannt
ob wir sagen woher kommen
der parcours war gut oder ob ihr das für
die sony psp wird dass sehr viele leute
mitgemacht
warum kann es explodieren das ist sie
nicht so viele leute aber ich glaube so
weiter wird der letzte sein weil das
schlechte zu konzeptlos cancer center
wie viele weil der zieleinlauf ist mir
auch in wettenberg ii ausgeben und her
gewohnt
ich bin 17 geworden war hat ja wahrlich
tnt drin hat ein riesig gefreut leute
wenn ihr ein video gegen cybermobbing
haben wollte zusammenstellen dann lassen
aber deshalb wollen wir doch was dagegen
machen heute ein bisschen verballert ich
habe was hat euch trotzdem gefallen wenn
ihr noch so ein video sehen weil checkt
buemi vorbei dann auch so was gemacht
und da war ich auch dabei aber auf einem
anderen server ja okay dann macht's gut
vorne